le concorde a volé six mois après la
terrible catastrophe qui avait coûté la
vie à 113 personnes supersonique est
allé de roissy jusqu'à la base militaire
d'istres dans les bouches-du-rhône
il fera pas en deux semaines des essais
au sol reportage patrick fandio
christian leroux et pascal quint un
petit coucou à quelques rares
admirateurs et le concorde d'air france
décolle de roissy pour la première fois
depuis le drame du 25 juillet dernier à
peine 45 minutes plus tard force bravo
se pose sans encombre sur la piste de la
base militaire d'istres
c'est la plus longue piste d'europe 5 km
de long 60 mètres de large
une installation capable d'accueillir
des navettes spatiales
mais c'est surtout le meilleur endroit
pour effectuer des tests de roulage au
sol à grande vitesse une batterie
d'essais que le concorde va subir
pendant les quinze prochains jours
il sera notamment équipée d'un réservoir
rempli de liquide coloré pour simuler
une fuite de carburant
la trajectoire et le débit de
l'écoulement seront analysées et filmé
ce matin le constructeur eads ex
aérospatiale a dû expliquer pourquoi il
procéder à ces tests sur un appareils
non modifiés
il n'y a pas de modification du
réservoir parce que l'objectif de
l'essai n'est pas d'essayer la
modification de valider la modification
en elle-même mais d'étudier le
comportement de l'écoulement du
carburant en cas de fuite légère et de
s'assurer que dans ce cas là il n'y a
pas de risque pour l'appareil d'ici
quelques jours british airways sera son
tour ses propres et c'est cette fois en
vol et avec le nouveau réservoir tapissé
de kepler
cette série d'essais ne sera sans doute
pas suffisant pour que le concorde e
retrouve son certificat de navigabilité
la question de la fragilité des pneus
reste posée tant qu'elle ne sera pas
résolue
il y aura toujours un doute sur la
fiabilité du supersonique